we know that our brain is what makes us
us it's what does all of our thinking
it's what processes all of the sensory
input from the outside world and creates
this reality in our in our brain that we
experience it is us
so the question is what is the brain
actually made up of and it's primarily
made up of neurons of neurons and these
are depictions of neurons right over
here
and the current view on how the brain
processes information it's by these
different neurons triggering by getting
excited and then stimulating other
neurons and as these signals go through
this huge neural network that has 80 to
a bill 80 to 100
billion
neurons
that that
electrochemical signal going through
this neural network is essentially our
thought it's essentially our
intelligence it's arguably essentially
us
so given that a question arises
what determines our ability to do things
what determines our intelligence
and one school of thought is that okay
maybe you're either just born with it or
you either have it or you don't some
people are smart some people are less
smart
or maybe you can change it and it turns
out there's actually been a lot of
research on this in the last few decades
and the answer is pretty clear that your
intelligence can actually be changed
what we've learned what researchers have
taught us is that our brains are
actually a lot like a muscle we know
that you can grow your muscles by going
into the gym and doing exercise and
straining your muscles you don't just
work on things that are easy for your
muscles to do you do things that your
muscles have to struggle with that your
muscles have to strain with and then
they rebuild themselves and they come
back stronger by struggling it's a it's
a signal to your body to devote more
resources to that part of the body and
we see that exact same thing with the
brain
and here are just a couple of examples
of it this first one this is
this is this shows how the human brain
develops in early childhood this is a
depiction of of the the neurons in a
brain at birth and then over as a child
develops it it interacts with its
environment it tries things out it
struggles it struggles to to talk to
converse to interact with folks to
understand the world around it and as it
struggles you see that by age six you
have a much deeper and much stronger
connectedness between the different
neurons
similarly similarly i can never say that
word this these are depictions of this
is these these are the neurons of two
different scenarios this is the the
nerves of
of animals that were in unstimulating
environments where they're not around
other other animals they're in a bear
cage and then this is this is the brain
of an animal that is in a stimulating
environment that is constantly being
challenged that is constantly looking at
stimulating new things and so the big
takeaway from this whole area of
research is you absolutely can change
your intelligence that your brain is
like a muscle the more you use it the
stronger it gets and that the best way
to grow it isn't to do things that are
easy for you that might help a little
bit but what really helps your brain is
when you struggle with things and it's
actually research shows that your brain
grows the most not when you get a
question right but when you get a
question wrong so at least for me this
is incredibly exciting because it lets
me know that when i'm going through
something and i'm facing those times of
maybe a little bit of adversity or a
little bit of frustration i can i can i
can feel good about the fact that those
are actually the times that i am growing
the most and this isn't just something
that i'm saying nice words research
tells us when you get something wrong
when you challenge your brain when you
review why you got it wrong when you
really process that feedback that's when
your brain grows the most and that if
you keep doing that
you're well on your way to having a
stronger more able and i guess you could
say smarter brain